comment va mon âme
au togo c'est magnifique
j'espère que là bas tu es content
sa femme lui manque un petit peu
enfin beaucoup
je travaille sur un projet pour te faire
sujet almar julie alice la date terminal
remonte à 208 mois et quatre jours
elle n'est pas prête à s'en aller non
bien sûr
on n'avait jamais connecter un pc à une
archive auparavant j'ai attendu très
longtemps et quelque chose c'était elle
[Musique]
on a reçu la visite de la société qui
s'occupe des archives ils pensent que
vous repos pourrait être basée sur leur
technologie
nous avons l'obligation d'user de la
force nécessaire je suis évaluateurs de
risque et vous
vous
est un risque
je sais ce que tu fais là temps georges
je veux pas le faire c'est aussi simple
que ça je veux pas être enfermé dans une
boîte quand je serai mort
vous les arranger les choses touré
pareil
j'ai l'idée ligne elle était parfaite
qui le rend puis c'est vrai
c'est ici chez toi
je vais ils me demandèrent vos
recherches
ils vont bien de chercher d'imagés avec
l'éthique
faux
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent c'est toi qui
veulent
n'existe pas c'est dans votre terre sont
pas des monstres qui causent les
accidents ce sont les pilotes négligent
pigeons
fouquet là mon coeur officier de
beauregard est je suis mécanicienne et
pilar diabate femmes dans l'armée de
l'air
ma mission est top secret c'est tout ce
que vous devez savoir
et qu à la fin macotakara erratique au
dessus sur la carlingue
on est en danger mécanismes n'existent
pas et ne boit pas
vient de s'attaquer nous appliquer à la
guitare
sécuriser notre ciel
content de vous revoir parmi nos ma
belle
certains diront qu'avec résultat vous
manipuler un processus tout à fait
naturel vieillissement n'a rien naturel
c'est une maladie il a de la chance de
vous avoir
vous êtes très belle tu penses vraiment
que ça fonctionne tu penses que ruben à
quel âge je dirais la quarantaine elle a
61 ans
tu rigoles vous pouvez me parler un peu
du trinôme comme vous doit bien
comprendre que je ne peux pas révéler
mes méthodes
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est inacceptable qui commercialise un
traitement qui n'a pas été approuvé
j'essaie juste de générer un peu
d'excitation
tu m'avais dit que les femmes étaient
volontaires
c'était le plan elle s'était pas
possible qu'ils aient 14 cas
j'aimerais que tu n'interviennent pas tu
ne me fait pas confiance
[Musique]
nous
ça va probablement faire un peu mal
[Musique]
il fait trop froid
les êtres humains sont ce qu'ils ont
toujours aidé et il ne change pas je
dois protéger ira il est maintenant le
meilleur moyen de la protéger de
construire un monde meilleur où elle
pourra vivre maintenant si tu restes ici
dans six mois tu seras moins si tu perds
tu trouvera peut-être un monde
ou tu pourra changer les choses l'impact
vous avez tué mais sonne pourquoi je
viens juste d'arriver ce n'est pas moi
vous voulez y ont passé un génocide pour
un problème technique de votre vaisseau
saturn 5 devrait être accessible à tout
le monde m'a dit n'en dites moi ce qui
se passe ici rien ne change si on ne
fait pas un petit sacrifice c'est vous
qui l'avez fait beau dit dites moi
comment pourquoi vous faites ça vous
êtes un terrien ne fait rien il n'y aura
plus de station oil et la caisse dans la
réserve du vaisseau c'est pour ma fille
[Musique]
espace oui quoi sidérer un découvrait
que votre gouvernement a voulu tuer des
réfugiés sens mans c'est magnifique
je me demande ce qu'on va trouver en
arrivant
et
[Musique]
et quand tu seras pas revenu
tu auras donner encore plus de sens est
d'importance à la vie de tous ceux qui
ont fait de toi l'homme qui tu es
[Musique]
bienvenue en irlande
il était une fois deux fermes voisines
la ferme des baux dont mme rosemary
vivait est au bout du chemin il y avait
ma ferme mon fils anthony aux essais
question solitaire aux étoiles
pourquoi m'as-tu fait ainsi rose-marie
monde donne était éperdument amoureuse
il ya ces champs verdoyants sur cette
terre viennent un peu importe que c'est
ça me retient ici
quand il dit des choses comme cela
mais pas dans patiemment moque tu
ressembles à john kerry
il était aussi timbre et la pleine lune
s'est noyé volontairement enlevé tomber
j'avais une roche attachée autour du cou
rose-marie on se connaît depuis assez
longtemps maintenant voudrais tu
m'épouser a dû signer les papiers pour
que la ferme soit cédée à andy voit pas
de lien direct entre quoi et quoi que
moi et toi ou en cousin respire tôt la
plus belle voiture l'udma bilan d' aller
c'est la ferme à un américain
le temps d après lui vous vous attendez
après quoi moi j'attends pas fixé mais
tu devrais venir à new york un jour
anthony ne se mariera jamais s'il faut
attendre encore je conviendrais mais ce
faudrait que tu te fasses congelés au
complet si tu as bien intention
d'attendre après lui
velho connaissent comme déjà eu un rêve
que tu poursuivait depuis l'enfance et
que tu n'arrivais pas abandonné tu as
mis cette barrière entre nous on reste
été rendue heureuse ou malheureuse
thual embrasser adam c'est lui qui m'a
embrassé c'est pour ça qu'il revient
j'ai du mal à comprendre les gens d'ici
pour rand est aussi compliqué vous
accepter des choses insensées
je n'aime pas me disputer qui aiment ça
la moitié vient landes mais pas moi des
foules vivre qu'on a moins chaud ni
froid je ne peux
je t'envie conflit en mars et que
l'amour
attention et à trouver
durant combien de jours verrons-nous
encore le soleil brille et ne brille pas
il brise un milieu qu'on ainsi qu'aux
[Musique]
et les je pense à des trucs sexy des
courses en gluten merde
est ce que j'ai dit ça à voix haute ah
désolé une seconde qu'est ce que j'ai
oublié d'acheter un peu dans les courses
maintenant je fais du sport
j'ai autre chose à faire tu est dégoûté
de tout ce qui touche au sexe ça c'est
parce que des bornes aux femmes
essaye de dire quelque chose de vraiment
crade
c'est à toi de décider c'est moi ou le
porno
après
je veux ta grosse est énorme
[Musique]
attention j'entre je voulais juste
m'assurer que tout allait bien quoi quoi
non j'suis en médiation méditation
méditation mais attends pourquoi t'es
rayonnante
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un alors j'ai
rédigé une liste de choses de qu à faire
le ridicule n'a jamais tué personne
[Musique]
je voudrais savoir un truc vous faites
du pilates ou waouh ça alors c'est
dingue ce que tu as changé
vous voulez danser
j'ai peur de ne pas être à la hauteur
je crois que tu as peur de te remettre
en selle mais c'est comme le vélo ça
s'oublie pas
[Musique]
c'est comme dans kraft tué devant
patrick swayze
[Musique]
comme ça je vais savoir tout ce que je
veux sur toi tu est certaine de vouloir
savoir pour l'état raison ça pourrait
être la fin d'une belle histoire avant
même qu'elle ait commencé où ça pourrait
être le début d'une histoire qui ne
s'arrêtera jamais qu'est ce qu'il ya là
dedans
il voudrait savoir comment fonctionne ce
truc excellent choix
j'en ai mis aujourd'hui commencez à vous
en avez mis mais si je crois que vous
avez mis de la crème pour les élections
se relève
[Musique]
zhoukov
need
[Musique]
les radios ps
comment
[Musique]
sacré
coût du gamma et
[Musique]
e
tu connais une situation la femme de mon
père va être saisie londres allait
reprendre avec born on en a besoin
d'être
[Musique]
tu vas ou mots ce qu'est ce qui se passe
en liquidation judiciaire
c'est clair c'est chez moi elle sortira
pas de la famille avec par toi
maintenant je me car et urcar dossier
solide mais regardez c'est vrai tu
serais d'accord s'il va me dit beaucoup
de bien de vous pouvez compter sur mon
soutien
merci la droite tu m'aides
[Musique]
ça sera votre part le contre la sienne
vos proches vont être interrogés ça va
durer longtemps
je sais pas à quoi ça sert de se battre
la suite on devait contribuer
ce qui s'est passé chez monsieur
rousseau qu'est ce qui s'est passé chez
moi vas-y di luca ce qui s'est passé
c'est parce que tu crois que tu te jure
c'est quoi alors pourtant
si c'était vrai tu vas mourir allen
attends je crois que j'en veux pas
penser à sa famille sa femme et ses
gosses
tu vas pas m'accuser moi aussi tâchons
60 euros qu'ils allaient soit 39
je prends mon courroux et bien je vous
emmerde
tu voulais jouer
[Musique]